when we introduced this topic this idea
of motion okay we looked at three
important equations that were related to
each other which we've considered
without the without connection to the
things that move but when we think about
things that moved these equations they
take on new special names so my only
specimens are also a special notation
right so the three are what this
straight-line motion topic was named
after namely displacement velocity
acceleration right now when we begin we
should we understood them in the most
sort of common-sense way which was as
functions of time right because that's
what they depended on so your one
function of time right if you know a
displacement is as a function of time
what will velocity did in this scheme
that I've got here it'd be it'd be f -
wouldn't it and by extension f double
dash so no problems okay
but then we move past this we sort of
developed further that you don't
necessarily have to understand how
something is where something is how it's
moving and what forces are acting upon
it you can understand not just new two
nodes of time but in terms of
displacement right so for example I mean
very quickly when we thought about
simple harmonic motion for instance we
had a think about X double dot and we
had it in terms of the displacement what
was the equation remember negative
squared X which was if your center of
version was just on the origin okay and
what was that slight variation we had
still negative x squared right but we
modified it by the origin so you got a
different set of motion that's all their
problems okay and this we remember these
equations they only apply to a simple
harmonic motion because you remember the
rubber band right this means but further
you are away the more you're being
pushed in the opposite direction okay
good
that was on this important mission but
immediately last lesson we thought about
another equation that was in terms of
displacement do you remember what it was
how do we understand it
remember we considered this we
considered X dot we thought about it as
a function of X right do you remember
this so I'm not gonna use that be
confusing okay so I think the example I
gave you was velocity equals e to the
negative x something like that I think
that was the idea right so this is weird
do you remember why we did this why
would it be important to consider
velocity in terms of displacement when
would that make sense
hmm I can think of an example you guys
know when you're when your parents
driving off or when you're driving along
right you're knowing there's a speed
camera right this speed camera coming up
you see the signs okay do you know how
speed cameras work
yes be cameras working on the UM on the
road is the road and here is a um here's
a car
okay sir it's going on the right I don't
know if you've ever noticed if you paid
enough attention okay but just
proceeding where the speed camera is on
the road itself on the actual ashphalt
right there are every time three lines
like this
they're quite dim they're not like
painted or anything they're just sort of
um they're the same color as the road
but you can see in this slightly raised
if you drive over them fast enough which
you shouldn't you'll feel them right
here's that here's the thing these three
dots they give a sort of point of
reference
you've got the UM you know where's the
camera look like something like this
okay it's on its stick right and ah
there's like another thing they said
actually I know what this other thing is
anyone know what that thing is the stay
next to it if the flash does anyone ever
see the speed eye camera flash go off as
they don't have a seen one go off at
night yeah it's blinding it's like a
flash of lightning actually um
just don't look at it now what happens
right what happens what's the camera
monitoring its monitoring you as you go
across these lines right these lines are
its marker for how it knows how fast
you're going right so what it does is it
measures you here and here and here it
takes three pictures right now it has to
take them without flash obviously
because it can't just be doing that all
day but if by the time it gets if you
get past this third one right and at a
particular place it measures your
velocity at us you know over the
threshold or whatever by the way there
is a threshold there's like as a roofer
error when there's a normal speed camera
but a second it goes under a school zone
the margin forever is gone there's no
it's not like plus or minus one
kilometre if you're like 41 KS in the
forties own it's over lose your points
anyway if you add a certain place right
a certain place have a certain velocity
that's what shake is it to actually fire
you take a picture of you in send you
some mail from the RT anymore
what's it call our RMS isn't it
anyway why are they calling themselves
this week right okay so we understood
the idea of velocity in terms of
displacement what did we do by the way
to start approaching this question and
getting it back to what this what did we
do with it we use chain rule how did we
use it we had to sneak time back into
the equation right and the way to
remember that was that velocity is a
change in displacement over time there's
time there he is okay
and so you could flip things upside down
and then you could integrate whether to
make the time and off you go
sorry with respect to edit